You know what else is incredibly infuriating?
Well, there's the global pharmaceuticals industry
that incentivizes disease because it's more profitable
to treat symptoms than address actual causes.
There's the global farming industry
that cause a lot of the causes
because it's more cost-effective to feed us things
that hurt us than the things that actually do as good.
And they also cause a lot of the starvation
because apparently artificial food scarcity
is really good for business.
There's the global industrial war machine
that incentivizes conflict and destabilization
because they figured out that getting politicians
to keep funneling taxpayer money
into their pockets under the guise of defense
is basically an infinite money glitch.
Then of course there's the other industries
that take advantage of that destabilization
to get their hands on cheap resources
that they use to manufacture their products
that they then get to market to us as environmentally friendly.
This does not look like a very friendly environment to me.
Then of course there's the global political establishment
that take money from all of these industries
and try and convince us that our only hope
to try and fix any of these problems
is to keep voting for them
and expecting them to do something about it
despite that obviously not being in their self-interest.
This of course all propped up by a global economic system
that incentivizes wasting resources
through over-production and over-consumption
in order to make money inflating itself
by merely existing by wasting the resources
that that money derides its value from in the first place.
We'll seemingly overseen by some shadowy faceless cabal
of banks and investment firms
who all own a percentage of everything
and all own a percentage of each other
in some giant circular economic cluster
fuck so it's impossible to trace the money back to anyone
and figure out who's actually in charge here.
So a lot, quite a lot.